hey folks I'm Dr Brett Weinstein this is
the 173rd Dark Horse podcast live stream
I am sitting next to Dr Heather Hein and
I have successfully mixed up the order
of the intro without anybody noticing I
would notice somebody with the dog who
was sleeping behind us
unperturbed she has our back she's
yes yes she does 173
we are informed by the universe and by
our friend it's not just Prime
not only is it Prime it's a feels Prime
it's a sexy Prime and not only is it a
sexy Prime it's part of a sexy Prime
triplet what does that mean I don't know
yeah well sexy is a play on the Latin
word for six
so it just means that it is part of a
prime uh if it was just a sexy Prime
part of a prime doublet uh that are six
apart and in this case it's part of a
triplet it's the Middle Prime in three
primes Each of which are six apart so
that's we are at 173 so it's going to be
167 and
179. 179. now do you remember the 171st
episode where I suggested that 171 felt
Prime
I wouldn't have been able to tell you
which episode it was but sure I believe
it was the 171st and you'd be surprised
how many people took me to task on that
sure
um any knowable information at this
point yeah easily knowable I mean I
wasn't pretending to know the answer I
was just saying it felt Prime which it
still does but their point was that
there was a simple method for knowing
which is something like if you're a
Pisces and the numbers add to nine then
it's divisible by nine or something like
that amazing also I think if you're not
a Pisces or don't know or give a rat's
ass what astrological sign you are this
also works here's the thing I am a
Pisces and I don't give a rat's ass what
astrological sign I might be but
nonetheless I got it wrong and uh our
audience successfully educated and
traumatized me over my error no it'll be
all right um I'm nearly over it yeah
that was eight episodes no we're in 176
two episodes ago yeah we're doing great
in the mouth today crime despite being
even
two yes ah yes okay
[Laughter]
um we're back at our usual time and
place and we will be uh here on
Saturdays at noon 30 Pacific for the
foreseeable future but there are some
changes coming uh we've got some new
platforms coming we've got some new ways
of coming at you coming which we'll be
announcing soon we're also going to
start doing Q and A's I think only twice
a month
um and we haven't quite decided
something like the second on the fourth
uh live stream of the month or the
second fourth Saturday of the month
something like that
um but we will continue doing our
private Q A's on uh at my patreon on the
last Sunday of the month so we encourage
you to join us there why are you
smirking Dr Weinstein
um two reasons one living in a permanent
Event Horizon saying the foreseeable
future now means
so little but I mean what else do we
have right it's just not a very long
foreseeable future
um and then
the way you said q and A's sounded like
a Confluence of a terrible set of
conspiracy hypotheses and a salary
spread yes exactly so um uh yeah it's
conspiracy garlics but conspiracy garlic
spread it is yes it's both and neither
um however today we are doing a q a
immediately following this live stream
or 10 or 15 minutes later so you can uh
go there now to darkhorsesmissions.com
pose your questions and we'll get to as
many of them as we can if you saved your
cues we've got a bunch of A's we'll try
to match them up yeah like one of those
uh you know really uninspired tests from
elementary school Highlights magazine
sitting in the dentist office that too
right yes where you have uh 10 objects
over here and sometimes 10 over here and
sometimes it's like 10 and 30. like
match them to their perspective
perspective perspective match them
that magazine always raised questions
for me highlights does highlights still
exist I have no idea that's how it's
exist outside of the US how many people
in our audience are we speaking to even
when it existed it barely existed I mean
it was a magazine that the existed
entirely in dentist office
right only where there was a captive
audience too young to effectively
complain about anything and before there
were televisions everywhere yeah right
so that I mean I think part of what
happened is now everyone expects screens
and they get them and it's
um it's easier and cheaper for offices
to supply screens with mass-produced
garbage than uh Highlights magazine
which
um yeah wasn't the most brilliant
children's magazine but it wasn't
terrible
well I don't know I
I always every time I picked it up I I
felt it was time wasted it was a lot
like a like a a preview of the internet
let me guess I actually know the answer
to this you preferred the back cover of
National Geographic world with its what
in the world game do you remember this I
do remember that so there were like six
or nine
pictures
a macro usually or something or or a
little on a feather yeah and and the
question was what the hell is this yeah
yeah I think it's been renamed wtaf I
don't know what it stands for but uh the
kids today they do yeah they do they do
okay uh what else top of the hour
Logistics stuff here we go
um Natural Selections we came to you
late last week so I had already just
posted my piece on sea stars but people
are enjoying it and uh I appreciate
subscribers both free and free and both
three all three now there's many um
actually tens of thousands of you are
free subscribers and I'm and I feel
wonderful every time I post something
you know that it's going out to to that
many people and um and of course I
appreciate paying subscribers as well
um I would just point out Jacques
Cousteau is the only c-star I can name
yeah yeah it's interesting um wow we're
just gonna go down all sorts of
um when I was in rabbit fish holes yeah
when I was in um Baja last in La Paz in
December of last year in Mexico
uh there are some lovely sculptures
along the malecon if I remember melson I
don't remember uh the sort of the public
walkway including one of Jacques
Cousteau that I now have is the avatar
for one of our seafaring friends so
whenever I think of him I now think of
Jacques Cousteau and vice versa even
though I'm not sure
not sure if that would be appreciated in
either direction but I just I have this
sort of thing I don't know I don't
really know much about the guy honestly
shock yeah oh we're not on a first name
basis so I no uh all I know is all of
those specials which were quite good as
I recall and you know the accent
irresistible
I may never have seen one
never have seen a Jacques Cousteau
special yeah I think that's possible it
is amazing over in the west side of La
we were watching land-based Mutual of
Omaha sponsored Specialists no that's uh
remember elephants and lion oh yeah and
jumping out of helicopters and darting
the out of stuff absolutely yeah
that was more my speech we're good
growing up okay uh we have an awesome
store
darkhorsestore.org is where you can find
stuff The Print Shop he makes all of our
merchandise and also runs the online
store
um is owned and operated Opera wow
which is so nice out I feel like I want
to be out there yeah let me go back the
store where you can find our merchandise
now
is owned and operated by this wonderful
couple in Louisville Kentucky
um so what that means is if you want
some Dark Horse merchandise like uh like
Pfizer the breakthroughs never stop so
bad shirts all that
um you are supporting not just us and
our store but also supporting American
entrepreneurs small entrepreneurs and
products made right here in the US which
is awesome and also these guys are never
going to censor us unlike uh the place
that we used to have our store based so
you can get for instance the Pfizer
stuff or the lie to a tyrant Google all
of that right there at
darkhorsestore.org and you can shop the
store outside just turn your brightness
up probably useful yes yes
uh and right here more local yet right
here in the San Juan Islands where we
are streaming to you from uh on Arcus
island is darvel's bookstore where you
can get signed copies of our book a
hunter-gatherer's guide to the 21st
century and you can order that online
but you can of course as always get that
book anywhere pretty much anywhere books
are sold still amazingly and we are
supported by you subscribing to the
YouTube and odyssey channels and the
clips Channel and sharing and liking
both our episodes and our Clips um
really does support us you can also
consider joining our patrons you had one
of your conversations patreon
conversations this morning Coalition of
the reasonable awesome and how
reasonable were they or were you they
are always reasonable and it was you
know it is very much like the experience
at least my experience I won't speak for
you but in an evergreen program
um which I attended to do in an
open-ended way the exact description of
the program the thing that you were
pursuing tended to emerge as the program
Drew to a close having come down all
sorts of different Avenues and these
conversations are a little like that we
work our way towards the concept that
we've been
wrestling into Consciousness anyway it
works works great and uh very rewarding
and very
lovely to see how many reasonable people
there are who are actually you know
serious enough about the question of
what we should do in Civilization to uh
to put in the mental effort and to
struggle with each other in an honorable
way and anyway it's it's great I'm very
very pleased about it that's fantastic
um I'm gonna make one snarky comment oh
God you said that your programs tend to
be open-ended
and uh I thought as someone who likes to
carefully craft architect uh many things
while still allowing lots of room for
surprise and Serendipity I say
half-assed your programs were not just
open-ended but open middled and often
open beginning as well but you got
amazing places and even more unexpected
uh than in programs that allowed a lot
of room for exploration but did have
some kind of mileposts laid out I
believe me as you know I uh admire our
son knows what I'm talking about yes he
does know a bit more I admire the
architecting of programs that you did it
was extraordinary
I didn't attempt it because I couldn't
have accomplished it we both know I
would have tripped over the attempt so
better to do it the other way but I in
the defense of the other way
we are talking about biology and my
point would be you know you could walk
into a tropical forest for example and
you could say all right Where Do We
Begin and you could come up with a bunch
of different rubrics about how to study
it you can study layers of the canopy
you can study trophic levels you can
study food webs whatever but the basic
point is you can start anywhere and the
fact is you all it all fits somehow and
so by studying anywhere you do tend to
make your way towards the the thing and
that worked well I will say
um
in my defense but I don't I don't think
any defense is necessary on either side
here that I took much more of that
approach in the field both domestically
and uh and tropically that although
especially on a long study abroad trip I
had to have you know planned a ton of
things in advance the actual like
um you know what is this day in the
field going to look like was very much
more likely to be actually you're all
going to go out there you're going to
explore and then you're going to come
back over and talk about what we saw and
what it meant and I think that was
actually
um
surprising to students who had worked
with me up until that point because it
was a change but my sense is like I'm
not I'm not going to tell you what
you're going to see because that's not
how nature works yeah nor am I going to
tell you what uh exactly what what you
might see will mean because you might be
seeing you know as it turns out the
organisms don't read the scientific
literature they don't read the field
guides they don't know what we call them
and they don't care and they often do
things that are utterly surprising and
so I mean it's remarkable
that in in 20 back then you know in the
20 teens and the 20 odds that uh you
know excited enthusiastic but unskilled
in the art of say uh observation of
tropical ecosystems students could walk
into a jungle and see things that maybe
hadn't been described by Western science
before actually you know and you know
I'm not talking about major discoveries
but
um oh well that organism isn't supposed
to do that yes but is it doing it well
yes well then it's doing it and let's
figure out what it means that it's not
supposed to do that yeah it's surprising
how often that actually happens yeah and
you know it can it can be that something
hasn't been observed or it can be that
it varies over space in the way that the
people who have observed the more
standard Behavior don't realize and
anyway all of those things lead to the
right place or that all of the
expectation the ethogram of a particular
organism was
made out the window of a comfortable
place in one concrete lined Pond for
instance just to take an example without
giving any more precision
okay oh excuse me
so
um you can join Brett's patreon with
open-ended conversations
to us one Saturday one Sunday of the
month usually the
La first but it's not this month because
we were not here I believe uh and so
fully asked but open-ended conversations
fully do you Chuck oh but I'm assuming I
mean you know people tend to bring their
a game so
what that's what a stands for I assume
okay
so you can also get access to a Discord
community at either of our patreons
where you can join a Vibrant Community
of people who are having great
conversations all the time and of course
finally we have sponsors all of whom
have products or services that we
actually and truly vouch for three at
the top of every live stream here we go
okay our first sponsor this week is
brand new to us
again another another brand new to us
which we're excited about better biome
b-i-o-m no e on the end maker of knobs
that's n-o-b-s
knobs is a new kind of toothpaste and
it's fantastic in fact we started using
this product several months ago and
approached them rather than the other
way around which is the standard thing
better biome again that's biome without
the e on end is a brand that you first
found Brett and brought to the rest of
our attention now we are all using their
fantastic product daily and can attest
that they are telling the truth when
they are when they say that they are a
brand focused on transparency safety and
efficacy
so let's talk about fluoride for a
moment fluoride is the anti-cavity
ingredient in most toothpastes that you
already know about but as we discussed
in our book under gatherer's Guide to
the 21st century the fluoride and
drinking water and toothpaste is not in
a molecular form that is found in nature
or it has ever been part of our diet
and Evermore research is pointing to
neurotoxicity from fluoride exposure
especially in children knobs from better
biome doesn't contain fluoride but that
in and of itself doesn't make it unique
because increasingly so-called natural
products are avoiding fluoride in their
toothpastes that said uh what are you
going to do as a remineralizing agent
many oral care products that abandon
fluoride don't replace it with anything
and so you end up with a product that
doesn't have any remineralizing agent
knobs includes a different and far
better one knobs uses hydroxyapatite
that sounds like some strange word but
uh it's actually hydroxyapatite APA
tight is the main component of the
enamel in your teeth and is in your
bones as well it's the hardest surface
it's the hardest structure in your body
it's been extensively studied in both
medicine and dentistry and is as
effective as fluoride in remineralizing
teeth without the toxicity of fluoride
hydroxyapatite doesn't just stop
cavities from forming there's even
increasing amounts of research
suggesting that it arrests tooth decay
once it's underway so knobs doesn't use
fluoride does use hydroxyapatite but
that's hardly the only thing unique
about it even most natural toothpastes
that are free of fluoride still have
lots of abrasive ingredients like
charcoal baking soda and eggshells which
actually you shouldn't be scrubbing your
teeth with that stuff knobs is none of
these things it also has no sulfates
parabens phthalates or microplastics no
BS it's right there in the name nobs
knobs you can pronounce it either way
you like knobs or no BS furthermore
knobs comes in the form of dehydrated
tablets
making them knobs which allows them to
be shelf stable without any
preservatives take a tablet shoot a few
times and brush as normal your teeth are
going to feel fantastically clean
because they are so check out knobs
www.betterbiome again without the e.com
slash Darkhorse that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-b-i-o-m.com slash Darkhorse
listeners can enjoy 15 off their first
one month supply of knobs from now until
July 17 2023. anything to add oh so many
things to add
um I would just say at this point that
it also solves a problem for travelers
it does the ability to transport a small
number of tablets uh which TSA will
never take because it's not a gel or a
liquid or anything right exactly it
doesn't have to worry about whether
you're volumetrically within range or
whether or not they're going to be
scanning it uh is absolutely fantastic
it also means that you're never going to
have the problem where you put the
toothpaste on the toothbrush and it
falls off into to the sink well what if
you put the knobs in your mouth and you
just like hang with your jaw open for a
while I can't protect you from you
but I can say that the toothpaste
falling off the brush because the thing
that holds it on the brush is a tiny
number of contact points that thing
doesn't happen so anyway there's a lot
to be said about how good this product
is and there's a reason that we
approached them so highly recommended
I'd be surprised if you didn't didn't
like it yeah
yeah so Zach our producer a 19 year old
producer just uses Velcro on his
toothbrush which while perhaps not as
abrasive a Char as charcoal or eggshell
still not recommended sir
yeah
okay well this is another reason to use
knobs avoiding velcro in your mouth for
instance okay this episode is also
sponsored by American Hartford gold if
you listen to Dark Horse regularly then
you already know just how incompetent
and unstable medieval institutions are
becoming
I could have just stopped at R couldn't
I have inflation is at its highest level
in 40 years interest rates are Sky High
where copper tune runaway inflation and
a recession and our leaders are
increasingly nonsensical all of the
certain businesses jobs and retirement
funds finding ways to secure your nest
egg and insulate your wealth is more
important than ever adding precious
metals to your assets is a great way to
stabilize your Investments and protect
yourself financially
American Heart for gold is a precious
metals dealer that can help you do just
that American Hartford gold helps
individuals and families protect their
wealth by diversifying with precious
metals they make it simple and easy to
protect your savings and retirement
accounts with physical gold and silver
with one short phone call they can have
physical gold and silver delivered right
to your door or inside your IRA or 401K
I think it's not physical if it's inside
your IRA or 401K but I'm not sure I
don't know it is okay okay so I think it
is
they are the highest rated firm in the
country with an A plus rating from the
Better Business Bureau and thousands of
satisfied clients and if you call them
right now they'll give you up to five
thousand dollars of free silver on your
first qualifying order contact them
today by visiting the link in the
episode description below or call
866-828-1117 that's
866-828-1117 or text Darkhorse to 998899
once more to reach American Heart for
gold call
866-828-1117 or text Darkhorse to 998899
all right our final sponsor this week is
mind Bloom mind Bloom is the leader in
at home ketamine therapy offering a
combination of scientifically robust
medicine with clinically guided support
for people looking to improve their
mental health and well-being if you or
someone you love is struggling with
mental health issues those issues May
Loom large in your life there is no
one-size-fits-all solution
but you know that you or your loved one
need something that will help achieve a
real and Lasting breakthrough maybe it's
time for you to consider a guided
ketamine Therapy Program from mind Bloom
mind Bloom can be your next most
successful chapter in improving your
mental health and well-being mind Bloom
connects patients to licensed
psychiatric clinicians to help them
achieve better outcomes with lower cost
greater convenience and an artfully
crafted experience
to begin make mind Bloom's online
assessment
make no
is there a word missing no I just read
the wrong word and I was thinking I was
doing so well on the reading today well
it says
to begin take mind blooms online
assessment and schedule a video consult
with a licensed clinician to determine
if mind Bloom is right for you if
approved you'll discuss your health
history and goals for mental health
treatment with your clinician to tailor
your mind Bloom regimen mind Bloom will
send you a kit in the mail complete with
medicine treatment materials and tips
for getting the most out of your
experience after only four sessions 89
percent of Mind Bloom clients reported
improvements in their symptoms of
depression and anxiety
reports one client on their site mind
Bloom has enabled me to release the hold
of negative thought patterns in my life
mind Bloom has guided so many people
into better a better chapter of mental
health and well-being right now mind
Bloom is offering our listeners a
hundred dollars off your first six
session program when you sign up at
mindbloom.com Darkhorse and use the
promo code Dark Horse at checkout go to
mindbloom.com
Darkhorse promo code Darkhorse for a
hundred dollars off your first
succession program today that's mind
bloom.com slash Darkhorse promo code
Darkhorse
[Music]
should we start uh in AI land or in
seafood market land
let's start in seafood market land that
will give the AI a little more time to
mature before we get to it which is
definitely what we want absolutely give
it a running start absolutely we want a
fair fight don't we I don't
I I don't know I I don't but I want the
AI to think that I do see
I'm impressed it's not no okay I can't
imagine that it would be no
um
okay so
um more research has failed to find
evidence that SARS cov2 emerged
genetically from the Juan it's spelled
one on
seafood market okay oh no the seafood
market is is spelled
h-u-a-n-a-n yeah uh I this is gonna be
like we don't speak Chinese so I'm sure
I'm butchering it either way yeah I'm
just going to call it the seafood market
from now on the seafood market there you
go uh so the seafood market in Wuhan
China
we talked uh several live streams ago
and live stream 166 about two months ago
uh in our live stream called corruption
capture and narrative control
about the then newest research that was
attempting to find evidence that SARS
Kobe 2 jumped from a bat to an
intermediate host like a raccoon dog or
a hori rat is one of the possibilities
now being discussed and from there to
people at the seafood market in Wuhan do
of course the Chinese people's tendency
to eat all sorts of things that
westerners don't eat
we have been talking about this since
almost the beginning of our live streams
over three years ago now but um we have
been saying that the evidence points
strongly to a lab origin since well
before that was uh since that was
considered Miss and disinformation
presumably and male information all of
that
um
those of us saying that the evidence
points to a lab origin indeed a lab just
down the street from the seafood market
have been accused of being racist right
because
um blaming three years of global Hell On
The Culinary traditions of the Chinese
isn't racist but uh pointing to
Scientific evidence that an
international
collaboration between American and
Chinese funding agencies and scientists
was the original source of the unfelding
hell is somehow racist okay
um just need to say that again because
every time I consider that that was the
thing they tried first to shut us down
you're being racist
no no you are actually like what is
wrong with you people but attempts to
find conclusive evidence that SARS cov2
emerged from a secondary host at the
seafood market in Wuhan continue there's
now been three pieces of research out
there we talked about one again about
two months ago then the Chinese released
some some research based on some samples
that they had taken in early 2020 at the
market before they shut it down and now
there's a new piece of research
nature news which again is like the
so-called journalistic arm of nature
nature being one of the two biggest
scientists science journals in the world
uh wrote the
following
and you might show my screen here now
Zach this is from May 4th 2023 Wuhan
Market samples fail to shed further
light on covet Origins
I would usually be showing the pdf
version of a document because it's
easier for me to have highlighted what I
want to share interestingly when I get
the PDF when I click that download the
PDF of this it's not the same document
it's similar but it's not the same
document that's the first time I've ever
seen that happen I don't know what
that's about but I'm going to read a
little section from this from this piece
here again published in nature news this
past week on May 4th signs of infection
neither of the two previous reports on
the animal sequences could confirm that
animals were infected with SARS cov2
Bloom's analysis also supports these
results
so I'm just going to stop there first
what kind of a crazy grammatical
construction is that
neither of the two previous reports
confirmed infection
this analysis supports the failure to
confirm that so this feels like
intentionally confusing language to make
it seem like there's something there
when there isn't
Bloom the author of the current study
investigated whether environmental swabs
rich and viral sequences were associated
with genetic material from a particular
animal which could be a sign of
infection but there was no such
Association that made sense says bloom
in fact the strongest associations were
with species such as fish cows and goats
that SARS cov2 is not known to in fact
says Bloom quote this doesn't provide
any more insight on whether raccoon dogs
or any other animal there were or were
not ever infected with SARS Kobe too he
says the swab data merely confirmed that
the virus was widespread at the market
he says again point of order I will say
that had he found what he was looking
for he and everyone else who's trying to
push this hypothesis would have found it
to be confirming but nothing can falsify
their cherished hypothesis they are not
doing science because they have a
landscape in which nothing that happens
can possibly falsify their hypothesis I
will continue with the nature news
report here
we always knew so this is from a
conservation biologist at the University
of Hong Kong Alice Hughes we always knew
that we could not definitively say if
raccoon dogs were carrying the virus or
if there had just been a co-mingling of
the DNA it says Alice Hughes a
conservation biologist at the University
of Hong Kong who was not involved in any
of the studies
making inferences based on precise
amounts of genetic material found in
environmental samples is problematic
says Hughes her Rey an adult in the room
some species are just going to be
shedding more DNA than others she says
because of the animal's size their
behavior or how they are handled and
processed at the market sequencing can
also introduce biases used because some
genetic sequences amplify better than
others all of this should be completely
obvious to anyone doing this kind of
research LSU's appears to be the only
person being asked about this who
actually is willing to say it out loud
still the bar and dabar was can you just
give me my screen back for a moment Zach
because I've forgotten it's in my notes
uh the bar is an evolution of biologist
of the French national research agency
cnrs in Paris she was one of the
co-authors of the first reports on the
animal sequences
so
um still the bar
emphasizes that the latest analysis is
important because it independently
confirms that specific wild animals
capable of being infected with SARS cov2
were at the market before its closure
it also shows that those animals were
located in the part of the market linked
to the most human cases which she says
adds weight to the hypothesis the
pandemic had a natural origin no it does
not
no it does not and if she is anything if
she deserves the credentials which she
apparently has she knows that too so if
I may have my screen back so I can um
continue my little rant here with a few
of the notes that I have first of all
that's ridiculous okay yep go on so I
have a bunch this strikes me as two
things one this is analogous to P
hacking obviously this is not
statistical right but the basic idea is
in a complex phenomenon you can get
spurious results periodically and we use
statistics to reduce the likelihood of
us settling on one of these spurious
results
um arbitrarily
it turns out that when you can play that
game so that you have lots of results
that have uh you know some low
likelihood of being the result of
sampling error that if what you do is
you hunt for the rare results then
you'll get something that appears to be
significant on its own but wouldn't be
significant if it was compiled with all
of the looking but in this realm the
basic idea is they're trying to build a
type of legal cases it's like well it's
a circumstantial case is the point right
they're trying to build here are lots of
things that would be true if some animal
had been infected and was in the market
and that's where people did get it but
the point is yeah you can compile a
bunch of things that would be true in
that scenario and no number of them
makes that scenario probable in light of
the evidence that actually does point to
the lab but what we're what we're doing
is we're you know it's also it's p
hacking it's building a circumstantial
case but it's also it's Akin it's very
much akin to P hacking in the same sort
of uh way that it misunderstands and
misapplies and misdirects people who
don't understand probabilistic thinking
right and uh the I'm a little bit
annoyed at uh whatever the author of
XKCD is who basically failed the covid
test right and uh was on the wrong side
of many issues throughout the pandemic
but prior to the pandemic he had a
cartoon about the association of jelly
beans I think it was with cancer and
anyway the cartoon really clearly makes
the the point uh Heather is going to see
if she can I thought I had it in a
computer but I'll try to find it here um
yeah I think if you do XKCD jelly beans
you could get it
that's not it
um that's going to be that's gonna be it
okay
yeah so uh for those just uh just
listening it's just a 16 panel 16
identical panels yeah to to scientists
one you can tell he's a scientist
because he's wearing safety goggles
um we found no link between purple jelly
beans and acne P greater than 0.05 we
found no link between brown jelly beans
and acne P greater than 0.05 pink jelly
beans blue jelly beans teal jelly beans
salmon jelly beans red jelly beans
turquoise jelly beans magenta yellow
stop me when I get to the you know gray
tan cyan whatever that is uh
we found a link between green jelly
beans and acne P less than 0.5 whoa this
is someone off screen uh we found out
and then we found out like mauve beige
lilac black Peach orange and uh that I
think the next the next uh XKCD is
breaking news link found between
um
I did but if I go out now it's going to
go into but if you if you I'm not
showing your screen
um
News Green Jelly Beans linked to acne 95
confidence only five percent chance of
coincidence except you saw and they did
it was a was it a four by four I think
it must have been a four by five because
he would have had 20 of them right uh
and that means that if you if you ran 20
of these with different colors of jelly
beans and one of them says oh it's p
less than 0.05 that is actually exactly
random chance
and so this headline borrows from the
one thing that doesn't look like a
negative result and proclaims it as if
none of those other tests happened yeah
so anyway one has the sense that this uh
seafood market explanation yeah it's
five by four is this kind of a game is
it a circumstantial case that you know
compiles a bunch of evidence uh that
does point to it and ignores all of all
of the countervailing evidence right
um is it analogous to P hacking
obviously there's no actual statistics
being done here but nonetheless it's the
same theme you know which is looking for
the rare piece of evidence in the sea of
neutral stuff that seems to indicate a
connection but it's also
um you know uh
it's that old routine from Get Smart
right which we've referred to before but
uh get smart which was a send-up of uh
James Bond in which Maxwell Smart is the
uh the man of intrigue International Spy
but he's also kind of a buffoon
yeah it's not it's not quite uh
Inspector Clouseau but nonetheless
there's something weird about uh you
know he's not dashing yes he's not
dashing he's not uh super capable or any
of the things that James Bond is anyway
he does this thing where you know his
his enemies who are
um the control agents control spelled
with a K who are obviously right this is
from the this is this is from before
time yeah
um but the control agents have captured
Maxwell Smart and they have him you know
in their clutches and they're going to
do something to him and he says you know
you know you think you have me but at
this very moment you know there's a you
know a squadron of such and such
descending on this building with blah
blah blah blah
and the control agent says
we think you're lying and he says well
would you believe there's one Squad in
the car and so that he keeps going
through a series of less and less
frightening things that might be
descending on the location seeing what
they'll believe anyway it's that right
it's like they're playing would you
believe it is that it's interesting like
would you believe doesn't work if you've
made all of your previous more ludicrous
assertions out loud
yes right and and this of course then
raises the question of how often is this
being done to us where they were
actually just barely Savvy enough not to
say the earlier versions out loud like
they happen to hit the right one first
where people were like oh okay well
that's okay I didn't know and you know
instead with you know the seafood market
and Wuhan they're just it's it is it is
would you believe it's multiple Smart
Style it's would you believe where the
punch line was delivered it's got to be
more than a year ago with frozen ferret
Badger Stakes right that was the
punchline and that was the point at
which we were all like oh come on like
there's nothing to that you just made it
up because somebody could imagine a
virus riding in a frozen ferret Badger
steak I mean you know it with zero
evidence they presented that as a
hypothesis and you know I think a lot of
people who were
who thought that this was an actual
scientific discussion at that point were
alerted aha but I mean a function like
one that's part of why I wanted to bring
this up again so nature news again the
journalistic arm of one of the two most
influential science journals in the
world
and they publish you know the piece that
I just read from is in their weekly
scientific journal so not only are there
what are deemed by the editors at nature
the most important scientific results
published every week in nature but
there's also the nature do section is
there it's not a separate publication I
mean Nature has like nature genetics
nature biotechnology nature like has all
these separate Publications this is in
nature itself right and uh
do you have something to say before I I
do I am tempted in an effort to put an
end to this madness to start the Frozen
ferret Badger Innocence Project right
yeah in which we've been together
acronym though
we yeah it's not much of an acronym but
uh but nonetheless I think it it has a
certain ring to it frozen Badger
Innocence Project yes uh I mean I guess
that that does raise questions about
whether or not they were innocent before
they were frozen or did the freezing
actually
um clear them with all guilt no I am
imagine as long as we're in the realm of
fantasy and we're not actually being
obligated to biology or the scientific
method or anything like that I am
imagining
my feeling is the Frozen ferret Badger
is actually an Arctic creature that has
been wrongly implicated in the uh the
covid pandemic named by some Arctic
explorer who saw them and figured they
must be frozen because here they live
yeah exactly yeah it wasn't the Frozen
inferiorate Badger popsicles that I was
imagining when they first I think was it
dasek who uh who proposed the Frozen
ferret Badger uh as source of the
you know because again those crazy
Chinese and those crazy culinary
Traditions that you know no this isn't
racist at all uh us subscribing um truly
insane
um things to other people and then
blaming them yes and how they eat for uh
what you rot
yes uh
He has blocked me dissect
um which makes me feel doubly good for
having called him patient zero for
misinformation on the pandemic it's very
very good back in the day okay
um a few more things about this this
ludacrosity that is is far worse than
just being ludicrous of course because
um they are actively and still
trying to rewrite history and this
particular one they've been doing from
the very beginning
nature news This research that nature
news is reporting on is a preprint okay
um that's fine
except that except that every single
time we were talking about pre-prints
especially early in the pandemic when
almost all the research was pre-prints
um we're told we can't that's bad you're
not doing science you're bad people
you're like clearly incompetent because
it's not peer-reviewed therefore not
science well a not true and B hold
yourself to the same damn standards
right so
this is a preprint wait if they hold
themselves to the same time well they
can't win is why they're cheating right
so we we get it we get like you're
you're behind the eight ball here but um
but you're wrong
um in fact not only is this a pre-print
but in this kind of Realm right in in
our realm often papers are are have
single or two authors
um but in the realm of virology
molecular biology everything they tend
to have like author lists that go on on
this is a single authored paper which is
I think I've never seen that in this
realm of biology before and
um that doesn't necessarily
say anything but it's unusual enough
that it was immediately noticeable uh by
me but what the single author has done
and this again not yet peer-reviewed
just pre-print paper he just he he did
some stuff and he put it on a pre-print
server and now nature news is reporting
on it okay
um is using data released by China from
the market in early 2020 he has and I
quote uh implemented a fully
reproducible computational pipeline that
jointly analyzes the number of reads
mapping to sarsko V2 and the
mitochondrial genomes of chordate
species across the full side of samples
I got it so it's a model
he has created some algorithm he's
plugged in data that the Chinese gave us
and
all he's done is introduced a new model
which may or may not be accurate anyway
we have no way of knowing because we
don't know what true is so how do you
assess the veracity of a model going
forward if what you're trying to do if
the only thing that you can are plugging
into it is stuff for which you don't
know what it means you cannot assess it
not science okay not not a scientific
investigation at all
you have become cynical you are missing
the obvious interpretation of the of the
single authorness and that uh Baroque
description of a model
he is academic distancing to fatten the
Curve
I mean that sounds like to me that
sounds cute but I don't know have any
idea what it's supposed to mean
if you imagine he's looking for the area
under the curve because that's the only
place you could hide a frozen ferret
Badger guilty of spreading a disease to
planet Earth right yeah then he needs to
enlarge the curve and he's going to do
this as a lone wolf academician which is
why there are no other authors on that
paper I don't know something I mean he's
not he's actually at Hutch he's actually
at the big Cancer Center in Seattle so
this is not a lone wolf wolf guy but
this little this
this one-off model
that we have no way of knowing how good
it is and even if it was good it could
not have demonstrated it could not have
said whether or not the hypothesis that
he was purporting to test was or was not
true
he's on a preprint server
and nature news is reporting on it
natured news is reporting on that little
dinky piece of what even is it so that
crazy
a description of what he did a fully
reproducible computational pipeline
sounds really fancy right um so as I
just said even if that clever model does
what it say it does and we can't know if
it does it doesn't have the capacity to
say what he hopes to find out right
um that is as um the conservation
biologist the University of Hong Kong
said in the little bit that I read like
this work can't do what it is claiming
to be trying to do so again just to
describe it again and I think I've done
this over and over and over again here
and before
even if you found out that say the
genetic droppings of raccoon dogs if
that's what we think it is now and the
genetic droppings of SARS gov2
were
um in higher abundance together in
samples from the market in early 2020
you could not then conclude that the
virus came from those animals you cannot
conclude that
so we've got this fancy sounding
computational model that may or may not
even do what it claims to do but even if
it did it could not demonstrate the
veracity or or the veracity of the
hypothesis or falsify the hypothesis
So This research is therefore not a test
of any hypothesis at all it can't be the
method may or may not be good we can't
know that from this but even if the
method were good it can't demonstrate
the hypothesis is true
and
the author of this paper the one author
of this paper is quoted extensively at
the top of the nature news article yep
so it's not even pretending to be
to be careful about assessing it so what
the author at the top of the nature news
article says the author of This research
is I would basically describe this as a
negative result
so even he knows
even he knows what negative result just
meaning like ah I can't say anything now
except that as I've already claimed
negative like what the god this research
like so much that has come before it is
set up so that they will make an
argument that if they get one kind of
result it's proof of and any other kind
of result is negative there is no
falsification possible so I have a
prediction so hold on
um why is nature news writing this up
like what predictions what is nature
news doing so if I try to go Devil's
Advocate on this
um they're highlighting that the samples
from the market early in 2020 aren't
useful going forward and in fact their
headlines seems to suggest that
yeah but
um
given that the research never could have
demonstrated that at all uh they didn't
need to be pretending that uh I don't
know if that's we're seeing glitches
here okay
um
This research couldn't have done what it
was claiming to be doing but the less
generous appraisal of course of why
nature news is writing about this
why the dedicated precious space like
this is literally showing up in the
print issue okay this is this is a piece
of so-called science journalism showing
up the print issue of nature which is
therefore still printed on paper with
ink using precious resources they have a
limited amount of space for this they're
publishing this
because it lends the sense so there is
lots of nature-worthy research being
done on the zoonotic origins of the
virus I
and that this is in fact the buzz in
scientific circles
and uh for those of you those of the
many readers of nature who don't
actually read especially all the nature
news articles like oh right yeah I did
see yeah just last week there was
another piece on the zoonotic Origins
not eternalizing that actually it was
based on terrible research that found no
nothing they found nothing but it
increases the kind of buzz around it and
the sense for people who aren't paying
close attention like yeah yeah it's not
a gorgeous lots of research cool
so it's PR it's not science
I I think you're on the right track but
I think I would predict something uh
predict something Beyond this
I would predict that we are going to get
a result that's going to claim to settle
the question which won't be the first
time they've built that on us but
of course
um I think the idea would be well so
this makes them look like they're uh
they're careful yes and even they admit
they had a negative result
but that first sentence where it's
basically a negative result
what is basically doing in that sentence
uh the sentence the the Jesse Bloom the
author I would basically describe this
as a negative result yeah what is
basically doing it I mean so honestly
it's not basically a negative result
because it's not science at all it's not
a result right but given that he doesn't
think that it's just yeah it's 100 a
negative result if if it were a result
at all
it would be a negative result yeah and
so the point is you know
it's I don't want to read too much into
the tea leaves but if the idea is you're
on team zoonotic origin and this is you
know you're going to be handed an L on
this one so that in the future you can
get a w then the point is well that
sucks I don't you know I don't love the
period where my L is being discussed in
nature news yeah but that's just long
game PR oh I agree but I think the point
is this is with a purpose would be my
guess and
um we will find out the next uh you know
it may be that there's another creature
that has to join the uh Frozen Fair
Badgers
yeah
yeah right right
um but in any case uh and raccoon dogs
of course
the overarching picture of everything
you have described here from this new
chapter is they cannot lose this one
right and we have run into several of
these in the pandemic where there's like
the garden variety industrial strength
um PR campaigns around vaccine safety
Effectiveness but for some reason the
epicenter of the misinformation is the
official narrative on Ivermectin and
hydroxychloroquine why presumably
because of the eua connection right that
was when they knew they couldn't lose
right just simply can't lose it this is
another one they just simply can't lose
because
if
these mofos
offshored work that was taking place in
the U.S to Wuhan to get it done
circumventing the gain of function ban
that have been instituted then the
entire pandemic and all of its bad
consequences belong to them oh look
three years of global hell it's on you
three years of global health and it's
the point is it's both sides of the
equation right by which you mean what if
they caused covid with gain of function
research that they offshored to
circumvent a ban then the point is you
think the vaccines are causing excess
deaths that's on you you think lockdowns
caused it that's also on you right it's
everything all the downstream
consequences all of the transfers of
wealth all of the evaporation of wealth
all of the insecurity that came to the
globe from this all of it belongs to the
people who made that choice
they can't lose it and basically they're
going to basically exhaust us that's the
idea right we're going to continue to
fight about the fact that everything
points to the lab and they're going to
continue to tread water and then they're
going to Spring some well no it turns
out we all thought maybe it came from
the lab even fauci said so but here's
the piece of evidence that says it came
from the the seafood market done
they're going to pull that on us and
frankly we have to remain Vigilant and
it damn well better be conclusive
evidence when they come up with it we
have we have to remain
Vigilant and
you know I haven't I haven't racked my
brains but I've thought off and on over
the last
three years
what
what would look like evidence right that
would be like it's their job it's their
favorite hypothesis they need to be
coming up with the predictions uh that
uh you know if true can only be due to
zoonotic origin I haven't heard any of
them but so they're not doing their job
they're not doing science but I haven't
come up with any whereas there's a lot
of evidence
for the lab origin for the virus not
being like any other virus that anyone
has ever seen in the wild even though I
think everyone on both sides of the lab
versus zoonotic origin question uh point
to a particular plate of bats which is
either where the virus sprang from in
you know
entirely or provides the you know
fundamental architecture on which gain a
function research was research was then
added I think the evidence you know the
I it's not the
some animal even in their fantasy world
it's not that some animal caught this at
the seafood market right right no it it
came in with the animal which implies a
population of wild animal that has the
virus or had it and the the only saving
grace of the story The only thing that I
think prevents them from just outright
manufacturing such a phenomenon in order
to bail their sorry asses out is that
they know that they would have to they
would leave evidence if they tried to
create a population that appeared to
match that prediction they find a wild
population of raccoon dogs near where
the bats live and infect them is that
the idea something like that that
they're going to end up tripping over
phylogenetic evidence that they're not
clever enough to fake that the problem
is they don't have the original virus
anymore well they have the original
virus but the point is either you've
stopped the clock on that original virus
or it has been evolving independently in
some population I mean I guess if they
if they've been continuing to do
research if any if anywhere
the research using the original SARS
Kobe 2 continued has continued to happen
and they might have something
phylogenically Downstream that isn't
otherwise they do but then the point is
do you really if you were them risky
it's very very risky because you're
going to suddenly have a bunch of
population geneticists and phylogenetic
systematists looking at this population
saying well that doesn't make sense the
population is too small for that amount
of you know you would get this analysis
and so well but would you I mean like
increasingly they've got two three
evolutionary biologists in their back
pocket who are trotted out to say this
makes great sense right so you know I I
don't know that I trust that the fields
that do have the expertise and should be
the ones calling the bluff on really bad
science that any people would actually
stand up
well I don't know if I re I mean look
there's a question why after they
screwed the world over by pretending
there were weapons of mass destruction
in Iraq and they were revealed to have
screwed up why didn't they invent some
weapons that would at least muddy that
claim right thank goodness they didn't
but yep nonetheless there's that's
always that's much easier to fake yes um
in this case they're dealing with other
companies don't evolve in place right
yeah
um in this case they're dealing with a
phenomenon that has so many tendrils
that are studyable and so many good
people who think about these I mean do
you really want to you know trigger Bill
Rice's curiosity over whether or not the
story you're telling about the evolution
of a virus in a population of you know
ferret badgers or hori rats or whatever
it might be it actually adds up at the
end of the day I don't think you want to
trigger that so my guess is they'd much
rather you know Cobble together a
Franken story from you know samples
taken at the seafood market then have to
deal with the difficulties of making a
plausible plausible phony
animal pandemic you know and you know
were they to be caught doing that
of course they would be risking an
entirely separate pandemic by taking a
virus that is human capable and
introducing it into a wild population
oh I think it would I think it would
because you know they
the the pandemic
cannot they cannot read to them as they
succeeded in cleverly managing the
narrative they've been widely revealed
to have screwed up not only the story of
the origin but the story of uh
repurposed drugs and Alternatives even
though people aren't as awake to that
portion they still that's a great thing
I don't think so at some levels it's a
different day at least there are
different days involved
whatever their gender might be but there
are different days involved but some of
the same players
um you know yeah
and you know vaccine safety and
Effectiveness and evolutionary
proliferation of viral variants all of
these things are places where they told
a very simple story and were revealed to
some uncomfortably large fraction of the
population as being Incorrect and at
best scientifically incompetent if not
um outright lying yeah no and I guess
you know part of part of your sort of
dystopian imaginings about
uh them you know placing a slightly
evolved version of a virus in
in a possible secondary host
um
would if discovered reveal that it
wasn't incompetence just like with
Watergate like the cover-up might be
evidence that but I mean I think it
couldn't be like Watergate because the
crime is too big here but the cover-up
reveals a different kind of criminality
than oh God we're so sorry uh look at
what we did
yeah we've been confused like they
for some people at this point the uh the
zoonotic origin people could still claim
I was wrong yeah I didn't know yeah
whereas a cover-up
no you can't anymore yeah yeah
all right
um I'm I'm done for now you're done for
now until they reveal the next uh
creature who will need a vigorous
defense from the Frozen ferret Badger
Innocence Project yes yes yes we might
uh there might need to be some
rebranding at some point because the
hori rat Innocence Project the raccoon
dog Innocence Project you know the
um you've never heard of this organism
Innocence Project
um I guess or I just think that the
Frozen ferret Badger could be the
emblematic creature shivering away
but uh you know
generating heat through yeah I guess
it's the spirit badges that are innocent
not the stakes
right exactly okay exactly all right I'm
glad we cleared that up because I think
a lot of people could have been confused
by that but no it's it's the fairy
Badgers themselves uh who are interested
and innocent yes yeah present but alive
brand it is the Arctic Fair Adventure uh
all right we could but I I think he
likes the alliteration
yeah but there's something about the
term Frozen it's just funnier
that's the alliteration Frozen ferret
yeah yeah all right
um
it is time
to segue into the next yes it is the
next piece which I believe is uh is uh
my piece here
where I just wanted to clear something
up it's not a huge matter and I want to
be very careful I'm going to use an
example tweet to illustrate the issue in
question I am not taking the person
whose tweet this is our friend
alexandros marinos to task for this but
I do want to suggest a refinement in our
Collective terminology surrounding the
discussion over Ai and I'm going to use
Alex's tweet to illustrate the issue
that I think is is uh is a problem so I
have no idea what's coming but he can
take it he can totally take it yeah all
right Zach do you want to show Alex's
tweet
and boom there it is can you enlarge it
a little bit yeah sure do
it says
uh I will keep reporting on this until
repeating oh maybe you should read it
you can see it better I will keep
repeating this until one of the doomers
finally addresses the argument
government
is this a quote tweet he is quote
tweeting someone named Gary Marcus who
says literally every conversation I have
on Twitter about long-term risk leaves
me more worried than when I started
standard counter arguments are mostly
these at homonym about who is in the
long-termest movement which is entirely
irrelevant to The Quirk question and
then I can't see the rest no okay so the
quote that's the tweet
that alexandros is quote tweeting and he
says I will keep repeating this until
one of the doomers finally addresses the
argument government control of AI which
is The Logical conclusion of their
advocacy increases existential Risk by
pushing AI Research into secret Labs
that are unaccountable and opaque
okay so let us just say I don't disagree
with the content of alexandras's tweet
here at all I agree that that is a
concern that the idea of we're going to
control this through regulation creates
an immediate problem
um about what that you know it's a black
box and that black box is a frightening
one however
the idea of doomers AI doomers is
increasingly circulating online can
the reason that I think we have to stop
doing that is that I believe that uh
like let's say conspiracy theorists
there's a question it may be that almost
everybody who's talking about
um some sort of AI disaster is wrong
about what we actually need to fear
right most people who are talking about
these things are talking about for
example the alignment problem where
let's say an AI gets an instruction that
it misinterprets and it starts doing a
tremendous amount of damage thinking
that it's following directions
that is a real risk but it may well not
happen right we don't know how big a
risk it is we're too early in the story
but that doesn't mean that everyone who
sees a disaster coming is naive about
the issue and I will say for those who
didn't see it and I passed episode we
outlined five possible disasters that
could come from the AGI era three of
which I believe are effectively
guaranteed there is no escaping them
they will happen how big they are is a
question but that they will happen is
not
and so those five involve
the two that we may or may not have to
worry about malevolent AI that views
this as a competitor and comes after us
that's one uh alignment where a confused
AI goes after us thinking that it is
doing what we told it to do that's two
those are the ones that are in question
then there are the three that I don't
think are in question one of them being
the malevolent use of AI by people who
are trying to make a profit or
gain power or something like that
there's no question that people are
going to leverage this very powerful
technology
and they are going to use it to transfer
our wealth to them whether it's by
tricking us into coughing up passwords
or by misleading us into voting for
candidates that they have leverage over
whatever it is that they're going to do
they're going to use it and it is a
powerful tool and I would argue it is a
more powerful tool in the hands of those
who are not morally constrained because
they're bad people than it is in the
hands of people who are morally
constrained and can only use it for a
more limited set of things so to the
extent that it empowers those who are on
the right side and on the wrong side it
will Empower those on the wrong side
more that's bad am I a Doomer for
thinking so I don't think so so I think
I'm just doing logic right
the second
catastrophe that is coming that I
believe is guaranteed
is a cognitive a human cognitive
catastrophe that in a world where
everybody has the potential to access an
AI and to be informed by it or misled by
it you have an infinite number of
feedback loops and amplifications and
distortions that are then going to be
impossible for any thinking person to
rule out so you're never going to know
when the person who is wooing you is
informed by the AI and you're dealing
with a Cyrano de Bergerac situation
or is the genuine article right you may
have ways of detecting it but the point
is everybody's trust needs to go to zero
that's like Step One Trust going to zero
is actually the right thing to happen
and then the question is you know
can you get out of that can you figure
out how to rebuild enough trust around
enough things that you can actually
function and it's a very difficult
puzzle to solve
right on that
um I have gotten a number of ads I've
never tried out one of these but um
because I don't not interested in using
it but a number of ads for exactly what
you're talking about which is at this
point just an app that implements chat
gbt builds it into your phone's keyboard
and so the ads are all about guys
talking to girls usually
um basically say they will suggest a
bunch of responses proper responses to
to exactly what you're saying so you
will have no idea it just comes through
as a text but it just builds right into
your keyboard you don't even need to go
to chat GPT and ask it anything
um and it does the analysis right there
so that's of course the Prototype
version it may not work very well as it
is but exactly what you're saying is
coming right along of course it's right
down the road and so the point is you
can you can make the first move right
you can outwit this to the first move
which is trust nothing
which is frankly almost one of the
pieces of advice that I gave you
right you have to not trust that you
understand anything you think you
understand because it could mean
anything in this era but the point is
there's no solution to that problem
right it's paralytic so paralytic may be
better than you know falling off a cliff
you're paralyzed at the top of the cliff
rather than falling off it but it's not
a strategy that you can use to make any
uh progress in life so that is another
catastrophe that is guaranteed people
will use AI against us that's one we
will go crazy as a result of the fact
that we don't know what our our
perceptual apparatus is no longer going
to be a reliable indication to anything
right and then there's the third
guaranteed catastrophe
which is an economic disruption like
nothing that we have seen right where
suddenly huge fractions of the
population are no longer necessary in
the rules for which they've trained have
no ability to move to some other role
and we don't have any preparedness for
this right we don't even have Ubi and
Ubi would be inadequate for this
so
so well and perhaps
um more quickly hasten the loss of the
sense of of identity and and purpose
right again like Ubi is a separate
question but
you if Ubi were to be implemented at the
same moment uh that people are losing
their jobs to machines I think
um I don't know how you hold on to a
sense of purpose if you know there will
be some people there will be some people
I trust who really were creative
analytical exploratory whatever and in
order to pay the rent
uh
they ended up in jobs and were still at
whatever moments that they had free
working to keep the artistic scientific
exploratory whatever it is peace is
alive
that's not going to be most people
yeah most people are just going to find
that they are they have nothing to do
but sit and look at their screens and I
that's terrible and that isn't the way
it has to be that isn't what humanity is
supposed to be but at this point if you
take away jobs and also at the same
moment
um
take away any sense of drive because
basic necessities are met at the same
moment
it's a it's a it's a Devastation unlike
anything we've seen
yeah let's put it this way it's an Event
Event Horizon
we can't see past it we can talk about
analogies right moments at which you
have a huge number of
males who are uh unoccupied and have no
meaningful prospects for starting a
family at home that's a situation
um ripe for abuse by Elites who wish to
arm those males and send them abroad
looking for uh for treasure
um is this an analog for that maybe uh
is this the self same object as the
um
centralized digital Bank currency
uh that becomes a mechanism of control
that keeps you in your 15-minute City
you know is this that right is the idea
that the elites who have seen this
coming maybe because they have a time
traveling money printer version and have
known about this longer than the rest of
us have they seen this coming and do
they understand they're about to have a
huge number of people who are at best
listless
who have to be controlled because of
what they will turn into if they are not
I don't know but I guess my point is
look it's an event horizon I'm not
claiming to be able to see what's past
it because no one can but you can
guarantee
that on top of people using this thing
to their benefit against the rest of us
um
and what was my
fourth category you have malevolent
people using AI for level ends the
Sereno de Bergerac style crazy making
yes the craziness right so you can have
a bunch of crazy people with no
prospects and vulnerable to uh bad
people leveraging AI against them that's
three separate disasters and I don't see
how any thinking person could actually
rule any of them out I think they are
effectively guaranteed so my point is
if I say I'm worried about a misaligned
Ai and I'm a malevolent AI in theory but
I'm willing to entertain the possibility
that those things actually might not
come to pass that nobody really knows
for sure whether these things are the
problem we think they are
um or whether they're manageable
am I a Doomer for thinking these other
things are coming and and in which case
should we all be doomers because does
anybody have an answer to why those
three things aren't going to happen
right right so anyway I guess my point
is Doomer is not a useful term because
what we really need now is Nuance in the
realm of what to fear and at what level
to fear it and there's more than one
none of these are mutually exclusive you
know that invoking Nuance proves you're
a Nazi right
it has been used as such it will now be
used much more effectively in light of
the ai's ability to massage the language
surrounding the connection between
nuance and Nazism but
um yes I don't actually think there's
much to the claim though it may become
ever more compelling as the AI
progresses yes indeed
all right
um
briefly two more things one is uh I just
wanted to bring people's attention to a
new product that is now authorized to be
used on produce including organic
produce in the United States
um it's called appeal
it's spelled like it's appeal of a piece
of fruit not like it's appealing to you
because at least for some of us it's
it's not really
um here
if my computer will come up okay you can
show my screen here
uh how appeal Works appeal keeps produce
fresh for longer thanks to the help of a
little extra peel our plant-based
protection slows water loss and
oxidation the primary causes of spoilage
so oxygen goes out but moisture stays
inside what could go wrong
uh learning from nature it's mimicking
the cuticle layer made from food to
protect your food note it's even being
put on apples where the skin of the
Apple isn't exactly a peel like I don't
know that I want this on my oranges but
at least with oranges some of them if
you're not zesting your oranges at least
you're not eating the thing that this is
on but it's also being put on fruit
where you actually most people eat the
outside layer of the fruit and I mean
Citrus is actually a bad example too
because a lot of us zest are Citrus to
and use it abundantly and
in
um in a lot of our food so
this is a thin edible post Harvest
coating made from plant Drive materials
designed to be consumed that meets the
FDA requirements for qualification as
generally recognized as safe in the
United States that's a technical term
generally recognized as safe grass
appeals at appeal is allowed for use on
fruits and vegetables in the U.S Canada
Chile China Colombia Japan Kenya Mexico
and South Africa without restriction
additionally it's a lot of use on a
limited number of fruits basically in
the European Union and Norway
Switzerland United Kingdom and if you
look through their list of fruits other
than Citrus it's fruits where normally
people are not eating the outside layer
now if I may have my screen back for a
moment they do claim
um
that
I wonder where it is well I'm just going
to read from my screen because I don't
see it on their website at the moment
another quote from their website appeal
is composed entirely of purified
monoglycerides and diglycerides edible
compounds that can be found in a variety
of foods they are safe to eat is
verified by regulatory authorities
around the world including Health Canada
the United States FDA and the World
Health Organization well then
what could go wrong in fact they are so
safe they can be found in products
designed for the most sensitive
populations including infant formula and
nutrition shakes for the elderly
sorry not a good enough argument when I
try to figure out exactly what is in
this this product I'm going to see if I
can find
the facts which I'm at the moment here
you can actually if you want show my
screen here Zach as I try to find
um yeah it's actually it's not how
appeal Works
um I've the facts have disappeared on me
so yeah okay
[Music]
I think I think oh yeah okay
um questions we've got answers all about
appeal yada yada yada yada what is in
appeal what does appeal made of that
sounds promising right
there was one ingredient in appeal
purified mono and diglycerides
it's one ingredient purifying
a food ingredient that is found in a
variety of foods and again the same line
the safety of these ingredients has been
verified by regulatory authorities
around the world the FDA the World
Health Organization in fact the
ingredient is so safe it is included in
products designed for the most sensitive
populations including an Ensure and
infant formula as well I'm sorry still
not good enough I can't tell exactly
what it is is it safe to eat of course
it's safe to eat it's only composed of
food grade ingredients made from
materials that exist in the peel seeds
and Pulp of all the fruits and
vegetables we already eat
aside from whether or not the thing
itself is safe to eat though
what is going to be the effect on say an
avocado and again I'm not their site
comes up with different things whenever
you click on things so I'm not coming up
but they've got this image of like 28
days in the fridge an avocado without a
peel and avocado with a peel on it
um the avocado without a peel you've if
you've ever bought an avocado and
forgotten about it
um you know what it looks like after a
few weeks in the fridge it looks
withered and wrinkled and if you cut
into it you realize you really don't
want to eat it maybe your dog does maybe
not it's probably best for the compost
pile if your dog doesn't our dog does
probably so unless we've got
some um but with appeal the avocado
still looks the same
okay the Oxygen's been going out
for 28 days the water's been staying in
what else does that do to the food that
you are eating
presumably
if an avocado
with its own resources could make it
last longer and therefore have a greater
chance of being found by the seed
disperser that avocados want to be
dispersed by it would have done so so
there must be some trade-off and these
people probably don't know what it is or
if they do they're certainly not telling
us
all of which leads me to the tagline for
these people which I kid you not is food
gone good
which suggests that when you just pick a
avocado or orange or an apple off a tree
it's not good yet what it needs is a
little technological interference to
make it become good
and then you can go ahead and eat it
this strikes me as of a type
this this product might be okay right
but this strikes me as of a type that we
are now seeing more and more and more of
I know no one likes to have their fruits
and vegetables Wither in the
refrigerator therefore we are going to
put something on them so that they don't
appear to have lost any water
what else happened though and guess what
the fresher your food
the better it is for you
and is that two-week-old avocado in your
refrigerator better for you than
something that was made two years ago
and made shelf stable yeah still
but it's far better for you if you eat
it when you buy it and we you know the
US apparently is tops in food waste like
we we do a lot of wishful thinking when
we're at the market and we buy stuff and
not we in particular but we do too like
we buy the Americans buy things put them
in their in their produce drawers even
in their meat drawers and things go bad
and that's terrible and wasteful the
solution is not slap a technological fix
on it and let's hope for the best about
whether or not the fruit Remains the
Same inside
the solution is eat fresh food when you
buy it
so there's a lot to worry about here
yeah am I right
it's amazing to discover that this is uh
happening at the point that it is
authorized right
um you know this is obviously a major
change in the way food is going to be
produced it's going to change a great
many things even if these ingredients
were actually safe which they may be
right
this is now going to make them a much
larger fraction of the diet right so
there's nothing that says that that's
inherently safe even if the ingredients
in some lower quantity are safe as you
point out there's a difference between
something on an orange peel and
something on an apple right we went
through this with alar and you and I
were kids alar was sprayed on apples and
then it turned out there was a problem
with alar oh yeah
so yep anyway there's a lot to worry
about here I I also get an echo of you
remember back when
it's an Aspartame is the sweetener that
was introduced that's NutraSweet yeah
um do you remember the commercials at
the point that this was introduced so at
the time saccharin existed it was known
that there were problems with saccharin
and it didn't taste very good it's still
in products though you don't know of
course yeah um but NutraSweet was in
introduced and people were already
alarmed about saccharin and so there was
a sort of like should you worry about
this and you have some with the cytom
margarine
right the ad campaign involved what is
NutraSweet well nutrasweed is made with
components that are found in many common
foods like so and so on and such and
such and I can't remember what it was
but it was you know like melons and
something and it led to the impression
that really that this was food that had
just been sort of slightly reorganized
right when in fact chemically it's a
much more radical departure from normal
yes and and has medical implications
that of course took years to emerge but
anyway the idea that something in a
broad chemical class that is common in
foods
right it's a little like if I said
um
you know what appeal is composed of
quirks that's it that's good of course
that's what all of your food is made up
yeah no it's quirks you're afraid of
you're afraid of eating quarks well
you're gonna go awfully hungry yeah
right so it's that kind of game where
the average person in the public is not
in a position to say well you actually
had you've said something that sounds
chemically sophisticated but you haven't
given me enough information to know you
know whether or not this version of it
is as safe as the version of it that
happens to be in the same class that I
do eat yes right so anyway it's all like
Shell Games and you know uh slick
advertising campaigns designed designed
to make something look friendly and like
it's a contributor to Earth well-being
because of course spoiling food is a
major cause of you know overuse of water
and you're not in favor of food waste
are you right exactly and you know
you're one of those people in favor of
food waste
I didn't know that but I I guess I'm
glad to make the discovery
can I share a few more facts sure
uh you may share my screen if you'd like
this is again from appeal site can you
taste or smell appeal after it is
applied no appeal is colorless odorless
and tasteless on produce apparently at
this point there is required to be a
sticker
but might that regulation disappear at
some point at which point you simply
can't tell and another part of the site
they tout the fact that it's invisible
if I am tastic great okay our
fruits and vegetables clean before
appeal is applied all fruits and
vegetables regardless of whether appeal
has been applied are subject to food
safety laws of the country where the
produce was grown as well as the food
safety lives of the country where the
produces so not an answer
what that means is
if we had to we did
if we didn't have to we didn't probably
it means and it means that you as the
consumer of something to which appeal
has been applied do you no longer have
the ability to clean off your fruit of
whatever it may have had before the
appeal was applied that's You've Lost
That can I wash a peel off no
you could they don't say no
but they say as you could likely remove
some of appeal with water and scrubbing
but it's unlikely that you'd be able to
remove all of it without damaging the
fruit or vegetable yeah yeah so again
like I wanted to mention this this
because
this seems fine like this is going to be
a thing that most people are going to be
like oh okay like there's bigger they're
a lot bigger a lot more important Hills
to die on than this one but
this is the kind of thing that is
getting more and more common I want my
food
to be food
I don't want my food to have
technological intervention that is
touted as invisible what to protect me
from myself to protect me from knowledge
to protect me from not being
non-compliant again well and you know
then we're going to increasingly run
into this with all kinds of nonsense uh
being introduced into food products in
various ways but the only if we even if
we have a label requirement right
effectively if you want to avoid this
you may not be able to right if it's
going to be sprayed on by you know will
a company that has fruit that doesn't
have the stuff be able to compete right
is your Supermarket going to have
organic food with this stuff and without
no it's going to have it with this stuff
unless there's an all-out Rebellion no
and Distributors and markets will prefer
it because then they you know because
right how like when did you last see and
I think the answer is never
uh an indication in the produce section
of a grocery store this is when this was
picked this is how long this is spent in
transit what you do is you hold it up
and maybe you smell it and you and you
assess it this is one of the I remember
the hard parts of very early coveted
lockdowns like I'm not allowed to touch
the fruit how am I supposed to choose
what fruit I want right so if if there
is no separate indication of when it was
picked and now you could be buying fruit
from a month ago yeah and because it's
been appealed there was no indication
you are already buying old food
and the producers who don't put a peel
on their food are going to be an
economic disadvantage because for
obvious reasons and therefore be driven
out of business and so you might predict
that you would have an increase in
deficiencies a cryptic increase in
deficiencies because people are eating
older food so their habit which used to
make them not deficient is now making
them deficient because of a change in
the supply chain that they can't detect
right
um I would also point out that the idea
that you can't wash this off the fruit
is also suggestive that's an awfully
durable coating it like impregnates or I
don't know I'm making that up but like
why can't you
hard to imagine it impregnates an apple
yeah
um and even if it does
right if the pores in the Apple are
enough for this coating to work its way
in there such that you can't wash it off
with soap then the point is it's sort of
Beyond a certain chemical threshold this
does not sound like
uh a normal component
um
maybe it is but it's a single ingredient
monoun diglycerides wait can I just
granted what they've said is very vague
intentionally of course but assuming
that it is roughly in the right
neighborhood of true whatever it's
supposed to mean that this is basically
mimicking you know the if you
peel an orange and then you bend one of
the peels in front of a candle or a
frame it'll catch on fire you're
spraying a little bit of oil oil and
also if you take an apple and like
just any apple and like rub it in your
hands for a while it gets really shiny
there are Coatings and such that are
bonded to the skins of lots of fruits
and I think it can like they showed an
avocado on their site and I can imagine
the same thing there
and so I think there are I think the
idea is you have some natural level of
Coatings like this on fruit which is
probably at that level for a reason of
course and that this is going to bond
all of that and just in increase that
well this is this is the app I can
imagine that they're right there that it
that that that's not inherently a
problem that it can't come off because
it is bonding to something natural
although I imagine there's a reason that
that level of those Coatings wasn't
naturally increased in fruits because
that's exactly right you know this likes
like
seemingly all of the technological
innovations
put the burden of discovery of what the
problem is on the consumer
the precautionary principle suggests
that that shouldn't be our job we should
be allowed to continue to buy food that
hasn't been messed with as opposed to
having to Think Through what all the
possible effects might be How likely we
think they are how bad they are if they
do happen and on balance whether or not
we prefer A over B so
um
what testing was done here do we know I
don't know I did not I did not delve
that deeply I know
um
how can I invest I know how I can invest
in appeal of Sciences it's a no I can't
a privately held company at this time
you want to hear the investors
let's not answered your question uh I
guess I'm curious now that you mentioned
the investors in the privately held
company appeal Sciences include Andreas
and Horowitz DBL Partners upfront
Ventures s2g Ventures Viking Global
Investors power plant Ventures temasek
and the Bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation huh uh what is what is the
appeal solution you asked like what
research was done I want to know what
safety testing was done uh is it safe
it's safe uh what if I have a food
allergy is a piece of peel a chemical
stupid question
um
read it appeal as many of the molecules
that exist in the fruits and vegetables
we already eat to learn more what about
what peel is made of click here I'm
clicking there
um product safe yeah but oh it's oh it's
been a molecule so am I
um
thin edible post Harvest coding
statement of compliance
regulatory information
ingredients a mixture of food grade
glucera lipids
yeah I don't product responsibility
for information sheet I clicked on these
they were not useful
but no they're actually very short
there's nothing here yeah yeah at least
for the US well I'd be very interested
to know how well it was tested and
importantly for how long it's very
difficult to test safety in something
like this because a as Dark Horse
viewers well know the animals that we
would typically test this on are
predisposed to endure chemical insults
that a human wouldn't but also even if
they weren't even if you used wild mice
instead of
Jack's lab specials you would still run
into the problem that mice are not
long-lived and so we typically use the
uh
um the rubric that giving large
quantities to a mouse over a short
period of time ought to tell us what low
quantities in a human over a long period
of time will do but there's no reason to
actually think that's true
um you know but it pencils out
the same amount over time something to
say but the point is what would I really
want in order to know that this was safe
well
you know I'm not a fan of primate
studies but I would at least want to see
long-term primate studies as in decades
and frankly I would I wouldn't want this
deployed over the entire human
population you know all at once for many
reasons including once again they're
going to deny us a control group right
right which is kind of their point I
think anytime you deploy something
globally you eliminate a certain amount
of your legal Jeopardy because there's
no control group to compare you to so oh
suddenly we see an increase in whatever
pathology well that could be anything
that's right
um so
this is a very troubling pattern and you
know we used to have a regulatory
apparatus that was at least on paper
obsessive about making sure that the
tests were done which was a never-ending
annoyance to the people who produced
these new products because it meant that
profits were a long way down the road
and might never be realized but that's
far better than a you know a
free-for-all in which you can bring any
old thing to Market because it's made of
quarks I mean you know it this is
nonsense it's it we might as well have
no regulation right which is what oh you
know the developing World faces pretty
much yep right that's where we're
becoming a global Banana Republic
perfect okay Zach has one more thing to
say before we finish off on hummingbirds
yeah someone mentions that we do already
put wax on apples and the point that
you're trying to make is that
the issue with this is there's no
control group you can buy many apples
with wax but you can also buy an organic
apple and I'm assuming that is supposed
to be free of that stuff I would also
point out that wax is a substance with
which humans have a many thousand years
but even if even if there was great
testing and this product doesn't
actually even if there's no problem with
this product whatsoever the fact that
it's going to be arbitrarily thrown in
the category of organic yeah can't make
sense that has to be a category that is
preserved as a real thing
yep
okay uh so just a little anecdote that
you have not heard okay um I was sitting
outside this morning working
gorgeous out and a hummingbird so we've
got uh two species of hummingbirds up
here in the islands in the summer
and uh we've got a couple at least right
in our backyard and one of them is
highly Territorial and he just screams
by and it's super agitated he'll go by
like six eight ten times if someone's
out there and yeah it really it really
seems to anger him that a person is
sitting in his garden and so this
happened to me this morning as I was
sitting at the at the table and like you
know he's terrifying the cats and I'm a
little less scared but uh still I mean
if he wanted to impale me I suppose he
could I wouldn't work out well for him
but
yes well exactly to this point
um
and
you know he seems to be upping upping
his game this week you know the
weather's glorious sex is in the air
he's you know he's he's definitely
interested in keeping out Intruders from
what he imagines is his space so he did
this to me a few times today
and I'm outside as it turns out Toby our
17 year old son was inside the house and
um he stopped on Midway like sort of
over me on one of his flights and almost
like almost looked like he made a
decision he's like oh yeah you're gonna
be in my space I'm gonna go into yours
and he turns like he makes a right
degree or a right angle turn in midair
and just flies towards the house and we
often have doors open but we had the
screen door
um open or closed at this point and not
the glass door and he flew into the
screen door
and got himself stuck no and as it turns
out like I was watching it and Toby was
watching it from inside so both of us
got up right away and came to to save
him
um and he figured out how to how to go
in reverse before either of us got to
him and like backed off and
[Laughter]
no actually
um it does it doesn't even leave a mark
like I mean you think you know needle
needles and beaks right and he hit it he
hit it just right but
um you know this was
an unexpected negative the effect that
we are having on hummingbirds I get I
mean I'm sure it was somewhat
traumatizing for him it's a hell of a
lot better than what happens when they
hit a window yeah no absolutely uh and
um I don't I don't know what else there
is to say I was you know as it turns out
two people Toby from inside the house
has been watching me get dive bombed by
this bird and I was of course paying
attention so we both saw it happen and
and the bird again reversed before we
had to get to him but uh
who knew that was even a thing I was
gonna miss that bird I'm glad he made it
I am glad he made it too yeah yeah all
right so I wasn't expecting that
um yeah that's it all right that's it uh
so we are going to uh come back with a
live q a in 10 or 15 minutes you can ask
questions for that at
darkhorsesmissions.com we of course
always start our Q as with a question
sometimes too from our Discord community
so if you're interested in joining some
awesome people there who whenever we're
coming up on a q a vote on what question
they really want us to answer this week
please consider joining us there on
either our patreons you can find the
Discord community
and you can always email logistical
questions to darkhorsemoderator
gmail.com we've been getting some really
fantastic pieces of mail to our
post office box it's also posted on both
of our websites and we enjoy almost all
of them quite a lot quite a lot
um until we see you next time be good to
the ones you love eat good food and get
outside be well everyone
thank you
foreign
[Music]